こん・にち・は
始まりました。はじめんチャンネル～
こちらにハエが写ってますね
まぁ塩が使えます
バッテリーが要りません
５０回連続射撃可能
ポップアップ機能がついています
あ～…あとはよくわかりません
A gun for the pest hunter Shoots like a mini shotgun
(ハエを駆除するための小さいショットガンみたいな物だよ)
というわけでこちら何かと言いますと
もう訳わからないどういうことなの…
まぁたしかに…ハエはいてウザいですけども
そんなぶち殺すほどじゃないと思うんですよね
純粋にね、興味で買っちまった
ハエを殺す用のショットガンで。弾が塩らしいんですよ
どうなんだろ、でも痛いかどうかもよくわからないんですよね
うわ～すごいガチっぽいなでも
わりとしっかりしてる感がある
本当にハエが殺せるのかな
no licence limit 誰でも使えますって書いてありますね
ここから塩を入れるみたいです
本当に塩入れるの
待って、うわ、これ、わりとガチじゃない？
なんかすごいリロードしちゃった
どうやって撃つの…？
え、わかんないワカンナイﾜｶﾝﾅｲ
おーとせふてぃー？
ヘッ
うわー・・・
うおぉー！
これ待ってめっちゃ強いじゃん
BB弾をいちいち買わないといけないじゃないですか、エアガンって…。
それがお塩で済むって結構画期的だと思うんですよねぇ
身近にあるものが武器になるってすごいよ。
あとは、果たしてその威力があるかどうかでございます。
えぇ、ほんとにお塩でいいのかなぁ
はい、という訳で一応お塩が入りましたー。
これでー
リロードしてー
戻して、ロックを解除して、撃てばー・・・
今出たー？
待って、肉眼じゃ確認できなかったんですけど。
え、出てなくね？
出てんのかな本当に
全然わかんないよ
出てます？
出てる！
出てる出てる出てる！
出てるなー
自分に撃ってみようかな
最近怪我が多いからもう怪我したくないんすよ
けどやっぱり自分で試さなきゃ
自分で試さなきゃだめだよ
撃ちます撃ちます
ああ、怖い怖い怖い
今日でチャンネル終わるかも
弟よ！
俺を撃ってくれ
待て待て待て待て
覚悟を決めろ
痛っ！
こりゃハエ死にますわ
うわ、これなるほどね
ちょうどいい具合にハエが死ぬ痛さです
痛－－－－－－－－－！！！
痛いけどなるほどって感じです。
ただ、顔にやっちゃだめだな
なんか程よい痛みだなー
分かるこの痛み
いてっーーーー
程よく痛いです
ちょうどよい痛さです
ちょっと弟に撃ってみましょう
絶対痛いじゃん
分かるっしょ
ちょうどハエが死ぬ痛さだよね
はいというわけで今から実際にこのお塩を
使ったショットガンで
下(の階)に眠る後輩をたたきおこしてやろうと思います
あいつはね今日俺んちに来る予定はなかったのに
無断で泊まったんで
それなりにねやっぱコストがはらわれるワケで
世の中には
世の中等価交換なんでね
一発　ぶちこんでやりましょう
(バンッ)
うわっうわっっ！
あれ？これ痛いのかな？思ったより痛そうだな・・・これ
へい！
わお！ぎゅぎょｖんｚｌｋ！！
あーう・・・